- Supplier power.
The bargaining power of suppliers to firms
operating in the industry.
Supplier should be thought of
as anyone who provides inputs
to firms in the industry.
These could be raw material suppliers,
labor from labor unions,
distribution services
from trucking companies,
even capital from banks
and venture capitalists.
The basic idea here is
to assess how easy it is
for suppliers to drive up prices
and capture margin from
firms in the industry.
There are several things
that impact supplier power.
The number of suppliers of key inputs,
the uniqueness of suppliers'
products and services,
the relative strength
and control over firms
in the industry, the relative
cost to firms to switch
between suppliers, the
threat that suppliers
might actually integrate forward,
and the relative costs
of the suppliers products
and services to the total
costs of firms in the industry.
Suppliers are powerful when
suppliers are concentrated.
For example, the number of
pharmaceutical companies
providing hospitals with drugs is low,
hence, they can charge higher prices.
When costs to switch between
suppliers are significant.
For example, when a firms
designs an electronic device
to use a unique semiconducted
chip, it gets stuck.
To change its chip, would require it
to redesign its product.
When suppliers could easily
enter the industry themselves,
that is forward integrating.
For example, GM and Ford could
easily become auto dealers.
Suppliers are weak when there
are many competitive suppliers
offering standardized
commodity like products.
For example, tires for automobiles.
When there are only a few
firms in the industry,
for example, paper producing companies
often vertically integrate back
in developing forests and cutting trees.